[Music]
happy Black History Month everybody out
there it's your boy Dorian here and
we're gonna watch Silence of the Lambs
honestly I don't know why I did it like
first of all like I was a little bit
high when I first started the movie but
as soon as I started watching it
instantly every other buzz was killed it
really shocked me how gross it was like
people told me beforehand it's pretty
gruesome but they didn't let me know it
was that dark I mean like within the
first 15 minutes people were talking
about biting tongues off and stuff like
that and I'm pretty sure like within the
first 20 minutes somebody threw jizz on
- what's her jodie foster's face all
right this is what are we doing here her
acting throughout it was phenomenal and
to see like her storyline progressed
with her being this FBI agent and by the
end she's like killing people but she's
still FBI training when we got to the
end when she was like in the dark ass
room with with the bill with Buffalo
Bill thought that was the most stressful
like 15 minutes I was being that typical
guy like screaming out of my laptop like
turn around he's like right there just
like start shooting everybody like she
had her gun and already oh she had a gun
out like ready to go and it dude like
that whole thing was just stressful to
watch until she finally shot him at the
end I was like alright alright Jody you
got it Hannibal himself like the other
nose of a golden retriever he's smelling
out everything in the book like when she
walk into a room he started describing
all that bells like okay when he started
reading her the first time like just
breaking her down verbally and he was
like started zooming in on her face I
was like I started feeling personally
attacked for I don't know why but it
just felt like he was talking to me
throughout the screen just cuz of the
the close-up zoom in when I started
watching these movie that I try to focus
more on the score and I thought it was
cool how in the background when Hannibal
with like before he escaped like the how
the music started to like add that extra
suspenseful moment I mean you knew that
he was about to do some good even though
we I saw it coming I was like that whole
scene with the music it just solidified
like how good this movie was going
because of that and then when he saw
like the whole twist when he's in the
ambulance and like he takes off the mask
I was like oh because I actually thought
he was the dude in the elevator and the
white that they shot his leg I don't
know why I thought it was him but and I
gotta say no black people who died in
this movie which I was thoroughly
impressed with because you know this
movie was in 1990s and it's a horror
thriller people that look like me
usually don't make it to the end of it
so shout out to them for not killing any
of
brothers out there because there were a
couple times and all that oh wait dude
no no don't do it but they all survived
so happy Black History if you see a
middle-aged white man in the middle of
the night carrying a sketchy couch and
trying to put it into a what looks like
a big ass white sketchy van don't go
over there and try to be a hero and be
like oh you need some help sir no just
let him try to figure that out by
himself there were too many signs I'm
not saying you deserve to be kidnapped
but before I went into this movie people
were like oh this is one of all time
graces as a vestment like one of the
best movies ever now I'm gonna be honest
I was not underwhelmed and I wasn't over
like I was whelmed I was I liked it it
was fine I didn't love it but it wasn't
like I definitely said go see it but it
don't go in with super high expectations
because people made it sound like this
is gonna be the best horror thriller
I've ever seen in my life I just it was
a it was a fine movie like once tried to
test me ate his liver with some fava
beans and a nice how do you say that she
is living with some fava beans and a
nice cheap how do you say I ate his
liver with some fava beans and a nice
Chianti dude that I can't
[Music]